gilles beck gilbert couturier bonjour
qui bonjour alors vous êtes le maire du
grau mans les conseiller territorial de
la majorité à la septième en 2017
vous fermez une bibliothèque ce n'est
pas inquiétant ce n'est pas choquant que
l'on ferme sur le symbole par excellence
de la culture de la connaissance de la
transmission je vais souvent fait des
tableaux dire bonjour d'auditeurs de
matinée première passe et à tous ceux
qui sont à l'hôpital en prison et à
toute la population qui se trouve en
souffrance mais au moins les choses au
sérieux je vois vous faites parfois on
en débat c'est cela m'interpelle
maintenant le nid un petit parole
matinée qu'à des canaris qadisha
jefferies bundle c'est souvent n'a pas
tendance on l'a on a tendance à oublier
au fait si il y à des situations qui
sont là qui a provoqué les situations il
ya un bâtiment ou non qu'on appelle
bâtiment léon gontran damas qui
hébergeait la bibliothèque du comment le
bâtiment dégradée depuis des années les
agents de qui travaillent dans ce
bâtiment au maroc et leur droit de
retrait en décembre 2015
à partir de ce moment ils sont
réaffectés dans d'autres services
d'école de bois joli à bois les à
l'école primaire le voit jolie ainsi que
l'école mixte à leur meilleure nation
qu'il qu'il mène baisse avec plaisir
avec sensations parce qu'ils n'ont ils
me font une bilan comédien
combien d enfants sont satisfaits
combien d un françois mai au lundi 10
mai la bibliothèque on pouvait la 10
place et peut-être chercher un autre
moyen
qu'entendez-vous pas autre moyen je sais
pas mais je vous pose la question
nous envoyons des bâtiments en bonne et
due forme et qui contemple ainsi une
cote ont dit place quand on va placer
une bibliothèque
il ya un certain nombre de normes à
respecter et à l'heure où nous parlons
nous n'avons pas besoin d'eux et
l'habilité qu'il faut fermer depuis 2015
maintenant lors d'un conseil municipal
qui s'était filmé en 10 20 derniers vers
juin
nous avons fermé le service afin de
réaffecter les agents d'un d'autres
missions toujours de l'animation est
permis tant ce que ces agents puissent
eux ou prendre continuer la mission
d'animation qu'il mettait auprès des
enfants auprès des parents et à partir
de ce moment là haut parce que je les ai
rencontrés voilà ce qu'ils m'ont proposé
pour qu'on avait pas vu venir la lah
bibliobus qui avant venait à dans la
commune d'automatique d'une convention
avec la bbc la bdp et bien on puisse se
permettre à ce que ce véhicule soit dans
les garanties parce que devant les
écoles de quartier qui ne bénéficient
pas de la biblio beef allah le veut ce
plus grand s'il en a le mieux puisque va
passer combien de temps dans la bâtiment
une convention donc on va voir avec eux
c'est qu'ils définissent le rythme parce
qu'il ya pas que le beau monde et dès
lors que ça va se mettre en place
2 concevoir une école de grisolles d'une
école de chaotique du magny à l'école du
glotin et à partir de ce moment là n'a
quasi pas paradoxal quand même j bercut
couturier de au moment où célébrer le
centenaire de d'aristide mauger qui a
été maire de la commune les a pressés
l'appeler effectivement il ya un mec qui
l'a limogé puis nous sommes dans l'année
c'est une bonne chose que ce n'est pas
paradoxal de voilà de fermer une
bibliothèque etc
est-ce que c'est pas paradoxal au bien
de ne pas débattre mardi devait pas se
dire moment ben oui on va on va trouver
une autre solution pour douala rebbah
prison ferme et ne vais pas dire livres
affirmé et je rappelle je rappelle que
si aujourd'hui si l'année 2010 est
éteint et d'équité a limogé lui qui
disait que si pas la population qui est
au service des élus mais les élus au
service de la population
eh bien nous travaillons tout autour de
cet homme politique mais aussi un homme
de lettres et bien nous continuons à
travailler parce que en fait dans les
projets de la ville
ce que j'ai dit aussi en conseil
municipal le 20 nous sommes en train de
travailler sur le palais de la
convergence aux pommes la culture dans
la plaie
à la place de la mdr ou ex mjc pour
pouvoir mettre là une médiathèque donc
tout est organisé
je crois que vous faites ce serait bien
que puis je puisse répondre
véritablement aux besoins de la
population et notamment des gens qui
sont en souffrance et j'ai besoin de
lumière j'ai besoin de deux groupes les
gens qui ont besoin de faire passer des
dossiers qui ont des maisons piteux état
je crois que c'était sa plus importants
et tous ceux qui pensent pas ce que vous
faites
le service étant fermées afin de
réaffecter les agents et bien si ça lui
aux gens c'est ça qui sur ça qu'il faut
c'est au fait je crois qu'ils se
trompent
et alors la bibliothèque fermée pas de
stades pas d'église mairie en travaux
n'ont pas vraiment de mairie est ce que
le groupe du jeune commune alors il ya
180 en 2010 est de 981 que notre
territoire et exige en commun donc
lorsqu'on exige un territoire
on met en place des structures et
fastueux et 6 les effectifs qui existait
on parle de marchi on parle de stade
tout à fait on parle de bâtiment
hébergeant la bibliothèque de que le bio
techniques et des menaces
on parle de la mairie
ce n'est pas en trois ans que ces
bâtiments en titi dit gandhi et 1 3 ans
ce qui mit au tour de ces structures
comme projet est bien le stade et à
mesure de tre les travaux peuvent
commencer
le plan de financement est en boucle et
le dst me suis dit rencontre les
dirigeants des utilisateurs du stade
le 3 juillet prochain à 18h afin de dire
comment ça va démarrer que cliquer sur
quelles bases qu'on va démarrer les
travaux
donc il a dit ou fait à quel niveau les
le projet se trouve sur l'église du
léman sa livrée l'église du gone et bien
il y à l'église étant inscrit aux
monuments des bâtiments de france donc
document notification que j'ai reçus y
est encore donc il y a une mission qui
en place qui est mise en place pour
faire je vais dire l'étude égrainé tout
ce qui a comme élément de le bâtiment
puisque c'est l'ensemble de l'église qui
a été inscrit et au niveau de la mairie
donc nous sommes les travaux ont
commencé il y avait un arrêt parce que
vous faites
il y a sur le bâtiment les entreprises
qui intervenait deux par rapport à la
difficulté ou difficultés financières de
la ville qu'on a mis du temps à pouvoir
régler
il avait marqué un doigt de riz très les
ans les entreprises
mais les choses ont été réglés depuis
deux trois mois et s'ils ne sont elles
ne sont pas là j'aurais fait un nouveau
point avec liés soit encore j'avais la
citer qu'eux au téléphone pour pouvoir
régler ces différents problèmes
alors justement on se range à rudy
gérance de la chose que le marché du vo
monde disparaît l'église en difficulté
il ya ceux qui y ont géré la commune est
en cours des gabegies qu'il ne réponde
aux populations qui s'interroge
mais au fait que nous qui sommes en
responsabilité depuis 2014
eh bien on va tenter chaque fois
d'apporter des améliorations et à partir
des plans de financement que nous avons
mis en place pour ces différents
chantiers les finances de la ville
justement on est en jeu d on parle de
déficit de la ville de deux millions
les déficits de la ville alors qu'on a
un problème de trésorerie
je peux entendre
on n'a pas plus menacé par un déficit
n'a pas de caf mais qu'on parle de
déficit le déficit qui existent dû à
quoi et on oublie que vous faites les
différents points qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui par hannity ses sept cent
mille euros que nous devons mais c'est
par l'équipe majoritaire le groupe
majoritaire qui est là qui emmenait ses
700 millions les différents gabégie
jardin du goût moon
différents travaux souvent au prix la
ville n'étant pas des travaux sur
l'aménagement du bourg place aux animaux
et que vous faites les travaux ne pas
terminer de colo groupe n'a pas donné
toute la somme alors que les engagements
ont été faits par là par la ville
l'équipe majoritaire qui hélas n'est pas
responsable si je crois que ce qui est
important c'est que vous faites que je
puisse répondre au quotidien de gonesse
et bien ça c'est bien ça notre priorité
est que vous ne vous dites pas un moment
ça manque afin d'aller à thala gilbert
couturier sa passagers non gauche voilà
brigands et je ne peux pas être celui
qui est critiqué les équipes qui étaient
là hier
et puis un jour je ne décide pas avec
des bonnes volontés et bien qu'on ait
pour pouvoir toucher du doigt la réalité
et puis ensemble trouvons les idées
ingénieuses pour pouvoir nous en sortir
des repas de fête et de fêtes 2010 est
2018 alors on donne il faut sortir des
priorités au moment où des gens ont
besoin de s'en sortir des gens besoin
d'être plus près des maisons des gens
besoin quand je vois au niveau du ccja
lui il y à épaules c'est important qu'on
puisse faire la fête je dis pas
historiquement c'est important pour une
population mais quand on est en
souffrance
on doit être en mesure de faire des
priorités voulais parler des indemnités
des élus à enlèvement dix places il on
est vraiment déplacé parce que c'est
nous qui dès le contre menton et
stabilité qui avons baissé sur le vélo
qui avait pour les élus et senouci qui
avons dit que nous créions un fonds
social des élus qui répondent aux
différentes personnes qui seront en
mesure parce que le palais gilbert
couturier je vous remercie à tout type
on en a parlé hier il appelait uk chaque
puits et nia manioc
[Musique]
donc